a meal for under a dollar twenty menu
rahma which means compassionate menu is
a government Initiative for restaurants
and food stalls to offer affordable
meals as a way to counter the rising
cost of living
more than fifteen thousand premises have
signed up to the program since its
launch last month
first you don't make a lot you actually
make a 20 25 margin so there's no loss
here okay the second part is that you're
helping somebody
helping the poor helping the ndd but
like many other operators he says this
can only be sustained at the cost of
ingredients doesn't keep increasing
the government imposes price ceilings on
certain items like raw chicken and eggs
to ensure they remain affordable
low-income families spend around 40
percent of their income on food so the
hardest hit by Rising food prices for
much of last year food inflation in
Malaysia was around four percent but
Rose to seven percent in November but
price controls have caused a supply
shortage and consequently higher prices
Malaysia used to produce enough eggs to
export but when the cost of chicken feed
started to rise and the controlled price
of eggs didn't poultry Farms reduced
production
I came to get eggs but they didn't have
the ordinary ones so I have no choice
but to get the special omega-3 ones
which are more expensive and that'll
affect my custom
the government says ill consider
removing price caps later this year the
country also subsidizes petrol and
electricity among other items last year
its subsidy Bill ballooned to 18 billion
dollars or around 21 of its GDP more
often than not and this is Malaysia is
not an outlier most countries due to
political economy reasons or whatever
price controls and subsidies tend to
fall into the pattern of the three use
so they become untimely untargeted and
time and you have all these attendant
problems as an issue
national debt is also Rising while the
budget deficit is expected to widen the
government says it wants to ease the
cost of living but it may lack the tools
to get it done
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Kuala Lumpur